This is the Chris Abraham show.
Hey there, this is the Chris
Abraham Show season 10 episode
5.
I did 1 early this this morning,
but I did it on the concept of
bias and the media.
This one is about my complete
analysis of Iran and not Iran
per SE, but why Donald Trump is
pivoted to Iran.
So about a year ago I wrote a
substat that basically said that
Donald Trump doesn't want to
invade other countries, but he
needs to find a way to stave off
a recession or a depression in
America.
So he needs to keep the economy
stimulated economically in terms
of for momentum and so forth.
And that his goal since he won
on an overwhelming American
desire to deport illegal aliens
quote UN quote that he could use
that as a de facto WPAA kind of
make work project and that make
work project would be the
deportation of illegals in
America.
Very simple.
You hire an infinite amount of
border control agents, an
infinite amount of ICE agents.
You build an infinite amount of
detainment centers.
You buy an infinite amount of of
private jets.
You contract and charter an
infinite amount of commercial
planes.
You then hire an infinite amount
of guards and security guards.
And then you of course hire an
infinite amount of builders to
build the infinite amount of
detainment centers.
Then you have to hire an
infinite amount of HVAC people
and security people.
And you have to hire an infinite
amount of medics and doctors and
an Infinity of judges and
lawyers in order to make due
process happen.
And then you have to do, you
have to hire a million, an
Infinity of people to do that
kind of work.
And then as a result, you also
build microcosms of supporting
towns and villages around the
infinite number of detainment
centers, like they have in
private prisons.
Most large private prisons have
entire towns, if not small
cities and villages that are in
support of them.
You know, like diners and hotels
and housing to support the staff
and diners and restaurants to
support the staff and cafes.
And the beauty of this plan was
that the only people who would
ever take those jobs are people
who would support Trump anyway.
Because anybody who is anti
Trump would never, ever take a
cent from him except to become
an employee as a gotcha
journalism kind of thing.
And it was running perfectly.
This was the plan.
It was going to be AWPA works
program, building program, and
it was going to spend a trillion
dollars of military budget
domestically and it didn't work
out.
There was so much friction
against this domestic plan of
deportation industrial complex
that it not only set off Donald
Trump's spite reflex, but then
he said, well, how are we going
to spike the economy if I can't
do my my big beautiful
deportation industrial complex
War on Terror, domestic War on
Terror, How am I going to do
that without the support of
people?
The only people who are vocal
about it are the anti people and
they say it's literally
concentration camps and
literally Nazi Germany and so
forth.
And since Donald Trump runs on
spite and Diet Coke and
McDonald's, one of his three
food groups, he said, well, you
know, I'm going to have to spend
that trillion dollars anyway.
Why don't we do it on everything
that nobody would give me credit
for?
So I don't get credit for being
a peacemaker.
I don't get credit.
Everybody laughs at me for for
wanting the Peace Prize.
Everybody laughs at me about my
FIFA Soccer World Cup Peace
Prize manufactured for me.
Everybody mocks me about the
Venezuelan recipient of the
Peace Prize giving me, giving me
her Nobel Prize.
Everybody mocks me.
So I'm going to show them.
I'm going to pivot and I'm going
to completely and utterly
stimulate the economy using good
old fashioned international
warfare, adventurism and
international bombing attacks
and so forth.
Because there's nothing better
than destroying, blowing up and
needing to reorder $1,000,000
weaponry and ammunition and
bombs and missiles and bunker
Busters.
And then to have the support
teams and get all the people who
are on the National Guard and
Army Reserve, get them back up
to being activated, and then
starting up the paranoia around
terrorism and about proxy wars.
And it's a boon.
It's a boon.
And it's completely spiteful.
And in the back of his mind,
he's like, if you just would
have let me deport all the
illegals, then I would not have
had to pivot this way.
I mean, I have to make sure I
win the midterms.
And it doesn't look like I'll
win the midterms based on
everybody's focus on the Epstein
files and everybody's focus on
fuck ICE.
So let's see what happens if we
completely turn the escalation
ladder up to 11.
So that's my analysis.
I don't think this is going to
be a very long episode.
What do you think about it?
I mean, if you want to go, you
can go to my sub stack, which is
Chris abraham.substack.com and
search for deportation
Industrial complex.
I will put links in the
description below so that you
can read them.
But I think that there was a
complete desire to make American
homeland to be the next
Afghanistan war.
But instead of trying to spend
money on hunting down and
liberating women and girls, so
to speak, by virtue of killing
Taliban all around the country,
he was going to spend all that
Taliban money domestically
through instead of modernizing
and exporting democracy to
foreign places and building
green zones in foreign
countries.
And instead of wasting all that
money creating bases and so
forth in Kabul that was returned
to the Afghanis anyway, or a
Green Zone in Baghdad or
whatever, he decided to spend
all of his Warbucks domestically
and making it so that the only
people who would take the
Infinity of jobs would be people
who would not be ashamed to wear
a MAGA hat.
I don't know if this is going to
be remotely popular.
I don't know if anybody's going
to agree with me, but I think
it's Infinity interesting to
think about.
And do not underestimate the
power of spitefulness in terms
of behavior of Donald Trump.
And I guarantee you, amongst his
friends, he's like, he, he's
like, you know, you made me do
it.
If you weren't so defiant, I
wouldn't have had to escalate
like this.
Now see what you did?
You're putting Americans in
harm's way and all that other
fun stuff.
So anyway, this was a very short
episode of The Chris Abraham
Show, Season 10, Episode 5.
But I think it was something I
needed to say 'cause I was just
listening to reportage and
everybody seems like they were
surprised as to the outcome.
But for me, I mean, he's a
businessman.
He needs to stimulate the
economy somehow.
And while it will probably
negatively affect the price of
silver and of gold and of oil,
then we'll of course probably
spike international terrorism.
It will, it will be like a bona
fide, like spite based fuck you.
You don't know how good you had
it and you made me do this and
all those other kind of things
that an abuser likes to say
about the person they abuse.
So mahalo nuiloa, Aloha kako.
Thank you very much.
Mahalo very much, Gracia very
much merci beaucoup.
And feel free to like,
subscribe, join, stalk, follow,
comment and recommend this
podcast to all the people in
your boogity boogity lives and
let me know what you would like
me to talk about.
Because now that the weather is
really good and getting better
all the time, it makes me
extremely happy to be able to
make these recordings out and
about in my sexy S Arlington,
Columbia Pike, Arlington
Heights, adjacent areas.
Talk to you later.
Bye bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.